So we've been talking about
sort of MAC models and BLP,
Bell and
LaPadula is one example of that.
That's the Biba model.
Anytime we talk about a model, you have
to say what's the nature of the labels?
How do you compare them?
What kind of rules do you have?
Similar to what we had in the BLP model.
The Biba model actually
is dual of the BLP model.
And this duality is because rather
than focusing on confidentiality,
which is what BLP focuses on,
Biba focuses on integrity.
Integrity is defined, somebody being
able to write or corrupt data.
The interpretation here is that, when
you say it is top secret information,
it is really top secret information or
something like that,
or the information indeed
should be at that level.
So think about the sort of, quality
of information rather than disclosure
of information that
confidentiality focuses on.
So it's dual because the rules actually
are opposite of what we had in BLP.
When you're concerned about
information quality or
integrity you want to read-up.
Because anything below you is lower,
I mean information with lower integrity,
you don't want to read that.
So reads in BLP you have read-down,
here you're going to have
read-up in the Biba model.
BLP you have write-up,
in Biba you have write-down.
So if you're at a certain level,
well, the integrity of
the information that you can create and
then write is either at your level or or
it's less integrity than
the level at which you are.
So you're able to write down.
Again, we're not concerned about
confidential disclosure here.
We're concerned about
information integrity.
Okay, so let's look at an example
to clarify this a bit.
Let's say integrity could be high
integrity, medium integrity, or
low integrity.
So saying information quality, think
of your favorite newspaper that you
trust a lot, let's say for me,
it may be the New York Times,
the information that appears there is
highly likely that I can trust it.
Your supermarket tabloid,
let's say at the other end.
Apologies to anyone who
may be a fan of those.
When you're talking
with confidentiality,
anyone, it's not about
controlling who can see it.
It's controlling how
good the information is.
So here it's high, medium, or low.
Compartment could be similar to BLP,
depending on what
the information is about.
Really, it's the topics of the document
that contains that information.
So label here.
So anytime I quote a model I
said I want to talk about,
what does the label look like.
So, high, medium, low is ordered again,
totally ordered compartments,
partially ordered,
because they are sets.
And, the model says low
integrity information should
never flow into high
integrity documents.